this is Tuesday November first seven
days until the 2016 presidential
election and this is the closer I think
says the loyal Senator in the 1962 film
The Manchurian Candidate about his
paranoia mongering colleague if John
Iceland were a paid Soviet agent he
could not do more to harm this country
that he is doing now Putin says Donald
Trump in his speech at Grand Rapids
Michigan yesterday about his opponent
Hillary Clinton who she likes to say bad
things about you wonder why the world
hates us a former senior intelligence
officer for a western country writes
David corn and Mother Jones magazine
this morning has provided the FBI with
memos based on his recent interactions
with sources contending the Russian
government has for years tried to co-opt
and assist Trump if said Donald Trump
about Russia during the third
presidential debate we got along well
that would be good the FBI reports NBC
News about Trump's kurzweil campaign
confidant has been conducting a
preliminary inquiry into Donald Trump's
former campaign manager Paul Mann
affords foreign business connections
wouldn't it be nice Trump said at a
speech at Virginia Beach nearly two
months ago if we got along with Russia a
group of computer scientists reads a
headline now at Slate calm believes a
trump computer server was communicating
with a Russian bank at least Trump said
last December when asked about Putin
allegedly having opponents and
journalists killed he's a leader unlike
what we have in this country I think our
country does plenty of killing also the
speech is short says the wife of the
senator Iceland character in The
Manchurian Candidate but it's the most
rousing speech I've ever read it's been
worked on here and in Russia on and off
for over eight years rallying a nation
of television viewers to hysteria
to sweep us up into the White House with
powers that will make martial law seem
like anarchy yes I have employed the
theatrical sleight of hand of conflating
two movie quotes with four actual Trump
quotes and three separate actual Trump
Russia scandal quotes being reported
today I have done this because one of
the fascinating terrifying joys of that
political science fiction classic The
Manchurian Candidate is that once you
buy into the premise that the Russians
would go to any lengths to influence who
becomes president of the United States
the rest of the plot quickly lines up
behind a kind of inevitable logic and
once you buy into the premise that not
the fictional film version of the
Soviets of 1962 but the real-life
version of the post-soviet Russians of
2016 would go to any lengths to
influence who becomes president of the
United States the kaleidoscopic chaos of
Donald Trump's fevered dream of a
campaign also quickly lines up behind a
kind of inevitable logic so think of the
inevitable logic of the plot points in
the screenplay of what we might title
the Trump Korean candidate two weeks ago
Trump who is continually again and again
even during the presidential debates
defended the Russians against charges
that they have hacked American political
related computer systems elevated his
bizarre loyalty to Putin to a new level
by actually disputing the classified
briefings about the hackings that he's
gotten in which our spies drew him the
proverbial map Trump continues to say he
would restructure the greatest wedge in
the world against Russia NATO and would
only lend American help to NATO
countries menaced by say Russia if they
paid up during the September
presidential forum Trump said Putin was
a greater leader than Barack Obama and
with no apparent irony Nora we're 'no
statin is a dictator cited putin's
approval ratings of 82 percent the same
month the second man trump named as one
of his foreign policy advisers carter
page was investigated by our
intelligence agencies for allegedly
meeting in moscow with the russian who
supposedly supervises their attempts to
mess up our election after years of
boasting quote i do have a relationship
with him trump is recorded on video
saying that he switched in september to
a full denial that he even knows lat
amir putin and trump has defended
putin's anger at the use of the phrase
american exceptionalism and trump has
refused to say anything when his own
running mate mike pence called putin
small and bullying and trump denied the
russians had any
thing to do with the downing of a
Malaysian airliner and Trump has
insisted Putin will never go into
Ukraine even though he went into Ukraine
in 2014
anybody seeing the plotlines of our
movie the Trump Korean candidate yet
there's one other writers trick to which
I must now confess I omitted from my
collection of quotations anything from
the New York Times report this morning
quoting sources suggesting the FBI
looked but found nothing necessarily
nefarious about that reported direct
line between a computer server in Trump
Tower and the Russian company alpha bank
nor The Times said has the FBI found
anything that ties Trump or anybody near
him to the conclusion of American
intelligence agencies the one the FBI
now seems to be finally grudgingly
agreeing with that the Russians are
trying to disrupt the presidential
election but I'd point out that The
Times report also confirms quote the
FBI's inquiries into Russia's proximal
role continue and The Times also quotes
an op-ed in its own pages from this past
August in which former CIA Acting
Director Michael Morell said simply
quote in the intelligence business we
would say that mr. Putin had recruited
mr. Trump as an unwitting agent of the
Russian Federation and some there is
only one flaw with altering that one
line from the Manchurian Candidate to
insert it into our script for the Trump
Korean candidate and have it read I
think if Donald Trump were a paid
Russian agent he could not do more to
harm this country than he is doing now
and that flaw is Trump may not be a paid
Russian agent he may just be stupid
enough or disloyal enough or anti
democracy enough or just evil enough to
be doing it for free
that's the closure I'm Keith Olbermann
watch this space